it was brought to my attention that
there is a documentary called the
sociopath and it is about the Republican
nominee Donald Trump and it is by been
how and interestingly the David Pakman
show features is featured twice in this
documentary a bunch of people emailing
me the the film was released over the
last few days I believe they did a
GoFundMe crowdfunding campaign they
ended up $1,000 short of the $30,000
goal but the film was made it is
excellent it is very very good
we appear in it twice and I encourage
you to take a look at it before the
election just searched YouTube for Ben
how that's h o w
the sociopath let's take a look at the
two clips where we appear here's the
first one this column republicans
against trump or rat for short they will
come over george as soon as they get in
line he's been atop the
RealClearPolitics average of national
polls for three months the Republican
Party is in an utter panic over what is
happening with Donald Trump in other
words the fact that Donald Trump
continues to lead national polls on the
Republican side Donald Trump and a
second moment where we are featured in
Ben house Donald Trump documentary the
sociopath let's take a look at that
second clip his charitable giving is at
best undocumented at worst a lie Donald
Trump's campaign has repeatedly
emphasized his generosity he is quote
given millions of dollars away the
Washington Post did a really good
investigation into Trump's claimed
donations and his actually provable
donations on this essentially saying
that Trump did not personally make
charitable donations this show is so
much better Pat with ominous music
playing behind it we should just have
ominous music playing the entire show
and I also enjoy how it cuts into a
super close-up shot of just your face
yeah when you're really getting to the
punchline extreme close-up yeah check it
out the sociopath then how is the
filmmaker the david pakman show appears
in it a couple of times and it's really
really good and it's worth watching